we're bidding in pool B for an award of
50 million pounds that's for providers
that don't currently have a presence in
the business market and that wouldn't
that would include us and how soon will
you know whether you succeeded in the
bid well at the moment the position is
that we know the process is going to run
we don't know who's gonna be overseeing
that process yeah and it so it hasn't
formally started so we've still got some
open questions but what we do know is
that that we can see that there's an
unmet need there that that at the moment
the small businesses a lot of small
businesses are unhappy with the service
that they're getting from their bank and
as a building society we know that we
can offer something materially different
so that's why we're gonna be bidding
obviously nationwide has been going for
170 or D is very very successfully as a
mortgage lender so savings and currently
can provide them why do you want to go
into business banking it's a completely
different skill set isn't it well that's
right our Heartland is in in mortgages
in savings and more recently in current
accounts where we have been the market
leader for acquisition of new current
accounts and the kind of businesses
we're talking about are not the
large-scale international businesses
we're talking about the sort of the
smaller end of the SME it's still
millions of businesses but they're you
know it's not just the butcher the baker
the candlestick maker it's that it's the
IT consultant it's the eBay trader it's
the web designer and these are people on
businesses that have got relatively
straightforward needs they've got money
coming in and they've got money going
out and we know from the way we service
personal customers in that way that
these are the kind of needs that we can
meet really really well why wait until
RBS makes this pot of money available
why not just launch a service off your
own back well it's a great question and
actually Nationwide Building Society has
looked at entering the business market
quite a few times over the years but
actually every time we've looked at it
historically the price of entry has just
been too high because it does need a
whole load of investment upfront in
terms of systems and so on the potential
availability of these funds means that
we can now get over that price of entry
if we're successful in our bid
it's a ferociously competitive market I
mean 85% of the markets helped by five
major plays it's taken Santander UK
years to just break into that top five
ranking
as well it's a very very tough market um
it looks like here and you're absolutely
right and also switching at the moment
is only around 4% a year which is really
low but we believe that a lot of that is
because the choice is from one bank to
another bank and we offer something
really different as a Building Society
owned and run for the benefit of our
customers our members and how about the
core part of the business we had some
figures out early this week from UK
finance suggesting that there was a big
drop in mortgage approvals last month
you concern that the housing market is
losing momentum
well I think there are there are a
couple of things there there's that
there's the mortgage market and then
there's that the housing market in terms
of the housing market we've seen
relatively stable slightly increasing
prices and and we don't see anything
that that suggests there'd be any major
change to that although of course there
are big regional variations within that
the main standout characteristic the
housing market to me is how few
properties are on the market
availability of housing stock on the
market is at thirty year lows and so
that supports prices in terms of the
mortgage market I would say actually the
mortgage market remains very competitive
and very buoyant because with mortgage
rates that have been predominantly
coming down for four years now even
people rolling off old fixed-rate deals
can often remortgage at a better rate
than they were on and what about the
likelihood of a rate rise in May do you
think the market can withstand that well
the yes I think a market can withstand
that a quarter point rise where only
translates through to you know less than
twenty pounds a month for for most
mortgage owners it's you know
significantly less than that depending
in in various deals people are on so I
think that although there are some
pockets of strain in terms of borrowing
and affordability out there I think the
market actually could withstand
quarter-point
very easy the question is will it happen